بعد 10 ايام على انسحابها قوات الاحتلال
تعود الى مخيم جنين في هذه الاثناء في
اقتحام واسع وتتمركز عند مدخل المخيم
تحديدا عند دوار الحصان في هذه الاثناء
قبل دقائق من الان اقتحمت عدد من الاليات
للمخيم وكذلك مدينه جنين واطلقت اثر ذلك
صفارات الانذار من قبل المقاومين الف
فلسطينيين لتحذير ابناء المخيم من وجود
الاليات وتوجهها نحو المخيم
واندلعت اشتباكات اطلق النار بشكل مكثف
باتجاه اليات الاحتلال عند توجهها الى هذا
المكان تحديدا الى دوار الحصان حيث
تشاهدون في هذه الاثناء سيارات واليات
قوات الاحتلال تتمركز عند هذا المدخل
الرئيسي للمخيم بينما بدا انتشار القناص
ناصه على اسطح مباني مخيم جنين بالتزامن
مع اطفاء الانوار وقطع التيار الكهربائي
بشكل كامل كما تشاهدون عن المخيم وعن
الاحياء المحيطه بالمخيم هذا المشهد الان
الذي نشاهده على شاشه الجزيره مباشره من
جنين يظهر اطفاء انوار مدينه ومخيم جنين
بشكل كامل مع وجود قوات الاحتلال في محيطه
على مداخله وبعد ما اقتحمت المدينه من
مناطق متفرقه من منطقتين اساسيتين من حاجز
الجلمه وكذلك من حاجز سالم من المنطقتين
الشماليه والشماليه الغربيه لمحافظه
ومدينه جنين القناصه ينتشرون على اسطح عدد
من المباني ونستطيع ان
نشاهد اضواء بعض القناصه المنتشره على
اسطح المباني
واذين يمكن تمييزهم بشكل واضح نتيجه
للظلام الدامس في محيط المخيم وكذلك في
محيط المدينه هذا الاقتحام هو على ما يبدو
وفقا لما تابعناه في لحظاته الاولى اقتحام
واسع من قبل قوات الاحتلال ومباغتة
حديث عن اقتحام من الحاجزين العسكريين
ووصلت هذه الاليات الى هنا اطلق النار
باتجاهها فيما تمكنت بالفعل من الوصول الى
هذه المنطقه
وهذا ياتي بعد عره ايام فقط على اقتحام
واسع واجتياح امتد ل ثلاثه ايام او لثلاث
ايام متواصله من قبل قوات الاحتلال قامت
خلال هذه الايام الثلاثه باجتياح المخيم
وكذلك اجتياح المدينه باكملها تمركزت في
عدد من المنازل قامت بتدمير وتفجير وتخريب
حوالي 600 منزل في داخل المخيم بعدما قامت
كذلك باقتحام اكثر من
3000 منزل في المخيم في اطار هذه العمليه
العسكريه التي قامت بتنفيذها وادى ذلك الى
اندلاع اشتباكات عنيفه بين مقاومين
فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال وادى ذلك الى
استشهاد 12 فلسطينيا واصابه سبعه من
الجنود في اكبر اجتياح لمخيم ومدينه جنين
منذ عام
2002 منذ الاجتياح الكبير في نيسان الذي
كان قد امتد الى عره ايام هذا الاجتياح
الاخير الذي انسحبت اثره قوات الاحتلال
بعدما قامت بتنفيذ عمليه عسكريه كانت
يستهدف القضاء على المقاومين الفلسطينيين
في المخيم
ووقف العمليات العسكريه المضاده لقوات
الاحتلال والتصدي لقوات الاحتلال الذي كان
يحدث في كل مره تقتحم فيه قوات الاحتلال
لكن هذا التصدي عاد وتكرر في هذه اللحظات
بعدما قامت قوات الاحتلال
باقتحام المدينه ووصولها الى مداخل المخيم